[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor of the daily mirror pepper
crearer and the deputy political editor
of the daily mail john stevens whether
from now until just before midnight and
welcome to both of you
so to the front pages then let's start
with the financial times which leads
with the governor of the bank of england
andrew bailey's admission that he and
the bank have been unable to stop
inflation hitting 10
chiefly because of a series of economic
shocks including the war in ukraine
well the guardian picks up on his
remarks as well bank chiefs warning over
apocalyptic food prices
the telegraph has a virtually identical
lead headline banchi food price rises
will be apocalyptic as you can see
and let's take a look at the daily mail
very similar bank chief families are
facing food price apocalypse
petrol firm profiteers failed to pass on
duty cart reads the times is headline as
tourists call for a crackdown amid new
highs in fuel prices delhi mirror
focusing on calls for a windfall tax on
energy firms to ease the cost of living
are expected to be blocked by
conservatives
here's the metro their headline proud to
say i'm gay referring to blackpool
footballer jake daniels who today became
the first professional player in the uk
to make such an announcement as also on
the front page of the i2 which draws
attention to jake's wish to inspire
premier league stars
while the sun leads with the libel uh
trial dubbed agatha christie and quotes
colin rooney in the witness box where
she described rebecca vardy's texts as
evil
reminded that by scanning the qr code
that you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
so we're joined then by pivot carrera
and john stevens welcome to both of you
and clearly there's news from mariupol
tonight and this asiv-style steel plant
but across the newspapers it is the
effect of the ukraine war that we are
reading about and uh the impact of
soaring inflation energy prices and of
course food prices per two and this
warning from the bank of england
governor
yeah there was a very striking hearing
in the comments today with um the bank
of england governor at the treasury
select committee in which he basically
was asked whether um he could do
anything more to control inflation and
he effectively said no
um this is obviously ahead of the latest
inflation figures which we're expecting
tomorrow
likely to top nine percent now if you
think about the fact that the target
initially was two percent i mean that's
dramatically higher but then the
admission from from him as well that
it there's very little that at this
point that um the bank could do
um
to to counter this obviously the bank's
been facing criticism they didn't do
more to put up interest rates sooner
traditionally that's seen as a mechanism
to try and control inflation and
although they put up interest rates um
incrementally in the last four meetings
that they've had they didn't do it at
the end of last year and andrew billy
made a point of saying that they
couldn't have predicted that the
european war was going to have this
impact although you know i think we
could contest that a bit lots of people
were talking about the prospect not
least in britain the prospect of a
russian invasion at the end of the last
at the end of last year um it's really
difficult for them though there are lots
of other external pressures uh not least
the the ongoing covert crisis in china
and the supply chain issues that that
has as a result here and bailey
suggested that about 80 percent of that
extra inflation that we're seeing is due
to overseas factors so much of it is out
of his hands saul painting a pretty grim
picture um as the cost of living crisis
continues to grip yes and the andrew
bailey um saying the most important
thing we can do is to get inflation back
to target um and many people are
suggesting and this is perhaps you know
the accusation is he was heading some of
this off that actually the bank of
england should have acted sooner john
what do you reckon
yeah well andrew bailey is already
coming under criticism from some people
within the cabinet and some tory mps you
saw mel stride who's the tory chair of
the treasury select committee that's the
committee
that was interviewing andrew bailey
today he suggested that the bank of
england had possibly been asleep at the
wheel over the last few months they
hadn't moved quick enough on interest
rates but this warning from andrew
bailey on food prices is particularly
striking you know terms such as
apocalyptic that's usually the job of
journalists to insert words like that
into stories didn't usually hear them
from the mouths directly of people like
the bank of england governor and he was
talking about how he'd had meetings i
think it was at the imf in washington
with the ukrainian finance minister and
he'd given a warning on food prices that
you know ukraine is obviously very
important across the world for producing
wheat and cooking oil and he was
suggesting that even though they're not
having problem with planting those at
the moment and harvesting
what they produce the problem they're
having is shipping it out of the country
and that situation is getting even worse
and so the suggestion that andrew bailey
was making that we're going to see food
prices rise even further which is going
to make life even more difficult with
people for people who are struggling to
make ends meet
the specifics the guardian uh saying
countries such as egypt and tunisia
we've always said north africa haven't
we rely heavily on exports of ukraine's
wheat and cooking oil and we know from
snake island right to mariupol you know
the black sea is is a tough place to be
is it not um you know and such a such a
crucial exporter of those goods um the
uh the daily telegraph again this word
apocalyptic i mean
how should people feel at home you know
the daily mail as well apocalypse
you know the people who are already
struggling see that word this this is
very difficult for people looking
forward to this year and knowing that uh
energy prices will go up again come
october pippa
yes and of course it's not just the sort
of international food prices that uh
people will be concerned about uh
obviously andrew bailey made the point
that he was thinking about international
food prices when he used that term
apocalyptic not necessarily who presses
the home though inevitably the knock-on
effect of inflation is of course that
they they go up as well we've also seen
diesel hitting a record of one pound 80
a liter on the four courts which will be
difficult for a lot of small businesses
and and drivers as well and that's
likely to get even worse if the eu
follows through um on its suggestion of
um of stopping importing any uh gas and
oil from uh from russia
that's gonna put more pressures on fuel
supplies off gem as well to the the what
energy watchdog announcing today that is
going to look at bringing um looking at
implementing the cap um four times a
year instead of twice a year so so
consumers are
therefore going to have uh
four hikes potentially of their fuel
bills a year in the next few years um
and all set against this this sort of
backdrop of the government so far um
making a sort of actually fairly limited
package of support for people through
their energy bills and the loan and
secondly through council tax rebates and
they're under huge pressure as every day
goes by to um to increase the support
for people and not to wait
until the autumn is rising has
consistently said
that he would do um you know the
government has also pointed out of
course their international um their
international
factors at play here but it's not just
that government made the decision to put
up tax put up national insurance and of
course to to freeze those thresholds
which is effectively a tax rise on the
same day um that other cuts were coming
in and that uh and the hike in the
spring hiking energy bills so the
government does have some responsibility
here for making the situation worse and
then not yet looking to um to make any
announcements in the in the coming days
and weeks um to to ease that pressure
but coming under huge pressure to do so
whether we see emergency budget or not
um i don't think that we yet we're there
yet but i think it's almost certain that
they're going to have to make some sort
of announcement before the summer on
extra support targeted extra support for
the poorest households
well while we reflect on the impact of
the war in ukraine let's just take a
look at the extraordinary photograph in
the times before we return to this issue
um this is one of the hundreds of
ukrainian soldiers uh under siege or had
been under siege in the mario pole steel
works because the breaking news tonight
as we hear from ukraine's deputy defense
minister in a video on telegram uh that
according to her 53 seriously wounded
servicemen have now been evacuated from
the asostell plant in mariupol to a
medical institution in the town of navo
azovsk in a russian controlled area and
another 211 people taken to olennivka
through humanitarian corridors these are
the images posted by reuters she said
that an exchange would be held to return
them home
apologies associated press these
pictures uh president zielinski has also
responded now in a video also on
telegram saying thanks to the actions of
the ukrainian military the armed forces
of ukraine intelligence as well as the
negotiating team and the international
committee of the red cross and the un we
hope that we will be able to save the
lives of our guys i want to emphasize
that ukraine needs ukrainian heroes
alive this is our principle and john the
uh the suggestion is that there will be
a prisoner swap but you know we've all
watched the pictures at as of style you
know in horror we've seen the injuries
we know they've run out of medication
antibiotics and so on um
is this ultimately you know a good
result for for ukraine and it's uh it's
fight against the russians
yeah everything that's gone on in that
place has been absolutely horrific and
the stories you talk about they're
running out of medicines we've just
heard them week after week the
absolutely horrific conditions there and
i guess it is a good thing that these
people have been able to get out it
looks like safely you hear those quotes
there from vladimir zelensky saying that
they have had to use a kind of prisoner
swap by
kind of releasing people in exchange for
these people but they must be just great
relief there that these people have
finally been able to get out of that
steel works
yes and pippa um we returned to
other matters in terms of cost of living
but i did just want to reflect on that
breaking news um the times is talking
about petrol firm profiteers failing to
pass on
duty carts um it's long been some angst
is it not the petrol retailers but
anyway what's this story about in the
times
so um the time story is um that the rac
has suggested that retailers are taking
two pence more in profit per liter of
fuel sold than they did before
chancellor reduced duty in march if you
remember there was a very big moment in
the commons when russia
decided that announced that um
that fuel duty would in fact in fact go
down has been obviously called for as
part of a response to the cost of living
crisis um and yet the rsc's found that
many of them had failed on this way
they'd fail to pass on nearly half of
that five-pence fuel duty cut
now um
bottom line is that this is yet another
area where particularly with
pressures on energy supplies uh
increasing globally as a result of the
ukraine crisis and
and sanctions that are have been placed
on russia and and
the west attempting to to um to
find other alternative uh alternative
sources of fuel um there are already
huge pressures on prices at the pump but
it looks like some of these firms are
also trying to make a a sneaky cut and
uh of course that's very much not what
the intention was of the chancellor to
give them sort of like the the room to
do that when he when he reduced uh fuel
duty that that he was his aim was that
that
fairly minimal cut actually when it came
to it um given the soaring prices which
passed on to consumers and that hasn't
proved to be the case so i think that
they will come under quite a lot of
pressure um if not from the government
itself and certainly from complaining
about benches of the likes of the tory
mp robert halfon uh to act and to uh to
pass on those savings to customers
instead
i'm just going to return to azov style
uh the reuters news agency is quoting
the general staff of ukraine's armed
forces
and says the ass of cell service men
have fulfilled their combat mission and
they were ordered to save lives so that
would imply they were ordered to
surrender
and continues to say that efforts
are continuing to rescue the defenders
who remain on the territory as assaf
style so we wait to see if there are
more who still need to come out of the
enormous steel works there in mario paul
we'll certainly keep an eye on that
story
well plenty more still to come on the
programme as well including we'll
continue to have a look at the headlines
the metro the headline proud to say i am
gay the blackpool footballer
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now the political editor
of the daily mirror pipa crearer and the
deputy political editor of the daily
mail john stevens welcome back to both
of you
plenty more to discuss then i'm afraid
we didn't get to see the mirror did we
the windfall tax you uh you talked about
but let's move on to the metro which
tonight is reporting the news of
the young footballer the 17 year old
jake daniels
hailed as an inspiration pippa of
becoming britain's first male
professional footballer to come out as
gay in 32 years would you believe it
this is a brilliant story i mean this
guy is 17 he's a teenager and he's been
brave enough to to come out in a sport
which quite frankly has is is the last
closet really when it when it
comes to sort of uh
open people are openly feeling
comfortable admitting their sexuality um
i mean
on the one hand it's pretty depressing
that
so more sportsmen more footballers in
particular haven't felt able to come out
over the years i mean when you think
about the
awful um situation of justin fashion who
um
who uh who came out and suffered years
of years of bullying um and uh you know
off the pitch and uh from some of them
from from the terraces and um
in other parts of his life as well and
and the sort of awful tragedy of what
happened to him as a result of that um
you know you you can understand why
others might not feel comfortable over
time um to sort of stuck their heads
above the parrot person the first so
that that all
really underlines just how brave jake
daniels has been um you know he i love
the i love the anecdote or he says that
the day after he told his mom and his
sister um that he was gay they were
obviously hugely accepting um he went
out and he um he scored four goals and a
youth fixture um for his team blackpool
against actress and stanley so he said
obviously there's a weight lifted off
his shoulders you know if he can be a
role model and show other gay male
footballers how it's done and how
actually it it just as it is no any
other bitter society is no big deal then
that can only be a good thing so good
luck to him i say and you know bravo for
feeling that he you know he wanted to do
this it's all of this in an interview
with with sky sports news and you know
the problem for people like him is there
is no role model you know everyone goes
back to justin fashion who and as you
said um back in 1990 um it is
extraordinary that we're still talking
about it isn't it john
yeah and he has shown tremendous courage
you just look at his words as well as
people were saying for someone who's 17
he just speaks with kind of
you know such strength and you know
someone with so much more experience
when he talks about how he knows that
there might be a reaction on social
media there might be a reaction in
stadiums but he says to people if they
want to boo him they want to shout like
shout as much as you want that it's just
not going to make a difference to him
and i think as well as being someone who
is kind of leading the way and showing
the way potentially for other
footballers i think he's also setting an
example for people at home that might be
struggling with these issues he's also
making football feel much more inclusive
for gay people people who watch the game
who now may have felt in the past that
they feel slightly
alienated by the culture in football can
now see someone who's gay playing on the
pitch that reflects them
okay john stevens peppa crew lovely to
have you both on thank you both very
much indeed